hi everyone welcome to our homeroom
livestream very excited about the
conversation we're about to have but I
will start with my standard
announcements reminding everyone that we
at Khan Academy we're a 501c3 were
not-for-profit we can only exist with
donations from folks like yourself so if
you in a position to do so please think
about making a donation I'll also want
to give a special shout out to several
corporations and organizations that
really stepped up over the last several
months when they realized that Khan
Academy was running was already running
at a deficit preak ovid and our deficit
only accelerated as we had almost two to
three times the number of users and we
tried to accelerate a whole series of
programs to support people through
school closures so special thanks to
Bank of America Google org AT&T fastly
and Novartis although even with their
support their very generous support we
continue to run into deficit so once
again if you represent a corporation or
even yourself every donation makes a
difference so with that I'm very excited
to introduce our next guest
dr. David Sinclair professor at Harvard
University David thanks for joining hey
Sal good to see you again likewise and
you know folks don't I mean I have
talked about in the past I you know I
have some fringe eating habits and so
I'm definitely very in kind of the
health world on certain things but a lot
of people don't know that I've actually
followed your work for for many many
years and you will get into it but it's
probably best coming out of your own
your own mouth you know what what is the
focus of your research and also what
what got you into it why do you want to
devote your life to this area of
research well my passion is to extend
healthy lifespan and people I don't like
people getting sick and so I'm a
scientist of medical school and we
research what I think is one of the
biggest biological and medical problems
of all time which is why do we get sick
especially as we get older and we all
know that our bodies are capable of
healing especially when we're young and
the question is why is that why is it
when you're young you can heal
from a wound or you don't get cancer or
Alzheimer's but as you get older you do
and that's what we're trying to figure
out because if we can harness that
energy of youth and even maybe even turn
back the clock in our bodies I think
it'll be the biggest medical revolution
of all time so you ask me why do I do it
well you know I think like a lot of
people I'd like to leave a legacy I'd
like to have an impact make the world
better than I found it
my grandmother instilled that in me
especially but I was also very curious
and I think that trying to tackle one of
the hardest problems on the planet
suddenly keeps me busy and very
entertained with my lab and there's a
lot in what you just said I mean maybe
the first thing that I've always found
it fascinating is you know we're always
caught up with the diseases of the world
you know and the big ones cancer a heart
disease diabetes but you essentially
just view those as side effects of
another phenomenon which is aging and
what I find fascinating about that is
you know hey aging is such a part of
what it means to be not even human what
it means to be a species as far as we
know it that we just we don't even
question that as being the actual cause
of all of these other things what when
did it click in your mind that you could
address aging itself and at the same
time you know there's all these other
you know Ponce de Leon looking for the
Fountain of Youth and so there's you
know how did you kind of navigate that
kind of fear that like wait this does
seem like something really important but
if I start talking about aging people
are gonna think I'm Ponce de Leon or you
know one of these folks looking for for
eternal life well it was like that when
I first started this is going back to
the late 80s Early 90s aging research
was the backwater of biology and to go
into it in a serious way was considered
madness had a number of mentors saying
why would you do such a thing
fortunately during the 1990s there was
some real big breakthroughs geneticists
one of which I worked for Lenny gurantee
at MIT they got into it and said okay
let's just throw out all these ideas why
we age let's just look for what genes
control aging and what we
as a field is that there are individual
genes that you can change that
dramatically extend the lifespan of
animals and yeast cells which I was
working on as a kid in my 20s but what
that told me and anyone who would listen
was that eight the control of aging is
extremely simple
now aging of course isn't in the same
way a car or work will wear out for many
reasons but if there's a way to slow
that whole thing down by changing one
gene it means it's possible to have one
day a medicine that would slow down and
perhaps even reverse aspects of the
aging process and as you said so what's
so important about this is that we we
throw away our preconceived ideas about
what's natural now getting heart disease
and cancer 100 years ago were natural
and very little could be done and the
same is going to be true for aging once
we accept as a you know medical
profession and I'm a scientist on MD but
if we can accept that one of the main
reasons if not by far the biggest reason
that we get these diseases as we get
older is because of Aging and the reason
we haven't made a lot of progress
recently or up until now is because too
many of us accepted it as an
inevitability now what just to make a
point I'm not saying that I'm ponce de
leon and i'm gonna give everyone
immortality that's not the point at all
and fortunately our field has gone ahead
in with leaps and bounds and now we're
one of the the most respected areas of
biology yeah and give us a few did
points you mentioned some of that early
research with in guarentees lab within
your case the yeast what are some would
you say is the seminal data points over
the last 20 or 30 years that have
started to make people realize that wow
there's a lot here and and i and i'm
from her with some of it but i'm
guessing a lot of people don't realize
what has already been done right i'm
often shocked and i when i talk to
people who are not paying attention
because they've got their own lives to
worry about um how far we've come and
and most people don't realize
so milestones so we've known for well
close to a hundred years that low
calorie diets can slow down aging in
animals and seemingly in humans
well then I was skipping a meal having a
fast it's it's always been considered
healthy and we didn't really know why
and actually you asked me why was I sure
that studying aging might be helpful
well the main reason is that when you
give rats and mice 30% fewer calories in
their life they live longer and and they
don't live longer because they stay old
they live longer because they don't get
cancer and these are the diseases of rat
aging or Mouse aging so I I knew that
there was something to be had there and
if diet can do it surely we can make a
medicine to do that as well and we've
made a lot of progress towards that so
some of the milestones were so the the
worm C elegans that's a nematode worm
there was a mutation in that called
daf-2 that extended its lifespan twofold
and now actually you can extend the worm
by tenfold so that's massive you can you
know you can in a lot you can extend a
worms lifespan by a factor of 10 by some
gene editing is that how you do it or is
it some molecule or both the best the
most careful ones are genetic but there
are molecules that now we can feed a
worm even even a drug that's on the
market for for transplant rejection
called rapamycin there are drugs that
can do what fasting hunger used to only
be able to do and another milestone was
we figured out that changes to how genes
are turned on and off in yeast cells
contributes to their aging as well we
learned how to control that in in mice
we can now extend the lifespan of mice
genetically pharmacological molecules
and one of the things that well there
are a couple things I want to say one is
that these these genes are found
throughout life they're found in yeast
cells they're found in worms they're
found in mice they're found in us so we
have longevity genes in our body and in
fact you can look at certain variants
and see if you're more likely to live
longer and then the other big
breakthrough was the realization that
the way we live our lives and the way
animals in the lab live their lives what
they eat whether they exercise if they
eat the right foods they're actually
turning on these longevity gene
pathways so we finally I think we have a
model where the reason that diet and
exercise is so good for us isn't just
because we stay lean and and because you
know our blood flow is it's actually
because our bodies have protective genes
we call these longevity genes and as we
get older and if we're lazy and we eat a
lot they shut off but there are ways we
can turn them back on by living the
right lifestyle um and hopefully one day
having access to medicines that turn
them on as well and and what you know I
think the difficult thing about this
research is obviously you can't study it
takes too long to study a human's
lifespan or how do you do that how do
you how do you translate the work on the
worms and the the mice and the rats to
something that you know works in humans
well there are business tricks to it
what we've done and I've launched a
number of companies to do this certainly
because a government grant won't give us
enough money to do that so the companies
we raise money we have traditionally
started companies where we see that
these molecules that could extend
lifespan in humans are also going to be
useful for diseases that need cures so
for instance as a company that is called
Metro biotech they work on raising a
little molecule in the body called nad
and it has potential applications in
rare diseases such as Friedreich's
ataxia or genetic disease without
without a cure as well as even
potentially treating kovat 19 we have a
study that's about to begin in that area
and we think that that will boost
elderly people's ability to fight
against infectious disease as well and
so just to make sure we're all on the
same page the way you do this obviously
it'd be very hard to run a randomized
controlled trial to see if some if you
can get some an average lifespan from 80
to 83 years that that research would
take forever and none of us would be
around maybe to see what happens but
instead you look at some of these
diseases that are associated with aging
and there you can see hey if this
gets this type of therapy this type of
drug or this type of lifestyle change
what happens to their what happens to
those disease conditions that's exactly
right
these molecules that I work on and other
scientists they could be applied to
probably a hundred different diseases
that are related to aging and some some
not sometimes these are just the ability
to boost the energy and the repair
systems of even sick young people so
that's also important to realize that
this research isn't just about keeping
older people around
it's about boosting the body's natural
defenses against disease and disability
and promoting healing and you're right
we can't do probably a million people
over ten years there's no country in the
world that could even afford that but
the hope is that if we can get a drug on
the market or even one that's already on
the market and show that if you look at
five ten thousand people over a few
years we should be able to see that they
have health improvements or at the very
least slowing down of the rate of
diseases that occur and there's a lot of
questions about nad that we're even
coming before you mentioned it and for
those super fans of Khan Academy videos
or anyone who has been paying attention
in their freshman biology classes or
their high school biology classes you
might recognize nad from respiration and
ATP synthesis so is that a coincidence
that for those who don't remember any of
these shows up all the time in the whole
Krebs cycle so explain is there
connection yeah so nad is this little
molecule that the cells used to carry
out about 400 or more enzymatic
reactions it's one of the most boring
molecules or at least it was up until
the 2000s but what my colleagues and I
realized was that nad levels also
controlled the body's survival networks
and the lower your nad levels we believe
the lower your defenses are and actually
as we get older and certainly we know
for sure in animals as they get older
they have less nad
or you can boost your energy levels
somewhat back up by doing exercise and
skipping a meal maybe once a day that is
is fairly well accepted but you can't
expect someone who's in a hospital or
who's elderly or sick to go for a run
easily right or skip meals so what we
need are potentially nad boosters this
is a group of drugs that I'm working on
intensively and we're hopeful that the
same kind of things that we see in mice
in the lab some of them will happen in
people and you know we'll probably know
in the next year or two or maybe sooner
with the co good 19 study but the kind
of things we see when we raise nad
levels back up in old mice of it there's
a lot of studies way beyond what my lab
has done but some of the things that I
know of from my lab are increased
endurance some old mice run further they
have much better blood flow are there
better blood flow in the brain as well
not just their skeletal muscle they're
resistant to heart attacks they have
less inflammation their respiration
their mitochondria I get revved up like
a young animal would so there are lots
of benefits that we can see in mice we
have a longevity study that's in
progress that's looking promising now I
can't say much more just yet because
people in my lab will kill me but you
know these are kind of things that hold
you know out promise that we can use
some of these changes in animals to
treat patients and ultimately if a drug
gets on the market for a particular
disease my hope my personal hope is that
now that drug can be tested in many
different areas are many different
disease areas by doctors and do their
own clinical trials in their own
particular area and eventually if
everything goes well we could have
millions or tens of millions of people
being treated with these drugs for not
just diseases but eventually we'll see
that those people on the drug hopefully
will be less prone to diseases and may
even live longer yeah there's a ton of
questions here from Twitter a Z latina
please ask dr. Sinclair regarding the
status of his research on nad new Jenner
Nero degenerative diseases I don't know
if that's the research that your staff
would kill you for talking about other
people are talking about nad infusions
and I'll be give a disclaimer here this
is not a place to get any medical advice
this is not a lesson for any of that
this is just we're having a conversation
please consult doctors etc standard and
then there's people talking about other
molecules which I know you have done
research on things like resveratrol or
you know people who've done research on
resveratrol starett I can never say it I
know the molecule terrorist Abilene
we start to the P Pateros Dib lien
however you know that you know how to
pronounce it better than I do um so I'll
just group all of those I mean once guy
I don't want to make any recommendations
of what people should or shouldn't do
with their lives people should do their
own research but I mean you mentioned
nad how does I guess if you could talk
about what you know about nad and
neurodegenerative diseases and also you
know how do you change any D levels and
say a mouse or in potentially in human
beings well in mice there are a couple
of ways that nad seems to work it will
raise the levels of or activity of a set
of genes which would call sirtuins and
many of those have been shown to be new
or protective again in mice now you know
it's easy to criticize these mouse
studies but you know in defense we have
to start somewhere but yeah there's
there's a lot of data from other labs in
particular a little bit from mine that
that you'll get your protection in
variety of diseases from certain
activity from Parkinson's through to
Alzheimer's and the second thing that
happens which I mentioned earlier is
that the mice get more blood flow in
their brain and we track that down to
the lining of blood vessels actually
become more useful and and grow in a
healthy way not nothing dangerous that
we can tell and and that makes me think
that there might be a chance to use
these so called nad boosting molecules
to treat vascular dementia which is a
very you know pernicious and common
disease actually with not much you can
do um so I think that there's there's a
lot of reason to go and explore nad
boosters in neurodegenerative diseases I
haven't done any myself in humans I'm
aware that there are some studies there
was one in Parkinson's there's one I
believe it was also an ALS which I know
is not new regenerative
central but peripheral but yeah I think
that that's one area the area that I
particularly worked on our muscle
wasting diseases and also immunity and
and what is how do you adjust the nad
levels in a mouse or or human is it is
it a is it an injection is it a pill is
it genetic G or whatever how you do that
well yeah I have to be careful because
I'm not prescribing anything I'm just a
PhD talking about science oh but let's
make that clear but there are molecules
you can give to a mouse there are they
called nad precursors these are the
building blocks of nad and we know from
Mouse and some human studies that that
I've been involved in that they will
raise nad levels in the body and the
hope is that by doing that we'll get
those soar to and defenses back up to
where they used to be when you're young
so you can take pills that's sufficient
some people do injections I don't know
if they work or not but I hear about
them but based on the literature you
know we're right on the cusp of learning
what these nad boosters are capable of
doing in people and many of them are
natural molecules so you know that that
piques people's interest as well yeah
and there's that you could imagine
there's a lot of questions about this
what well actually there's some
philosophical there's some medical
questions so let's go the medical ones
first so you know Madonna Checotah from
Facebook she's 60 years old she's saying
how many years before we see a cocktail
of drugs that extend lives so obviously
you know no one can predict the future
but you're you're really at the
forefront of where this research is what
do you think things are going to look
like in five or ten years when do you
think this is going to become very
relevant to you know the average person
watching us right now
there are I'd lost estimate 20 companies
who are either close to or running
clinical trials that came out of aging
research I'm hopeful that one or more of
them will be successful in the coming
years
how long till we have a cocktail it's
probably more than that you know the
drug development as I've learned in my
career is extremely tough and plenty of
things can stop you so I'm always a bit
cautious about making predictions for
the future there is there are drugs
actually that are on the market one I
mentioned which is reclamation which is
not something you take lightly because
it has some toxicity but there's another
one for example called metformin which
anybody almost anybody who has type 2 or
age associated diabetes will know of
it's also called glucophage which lowers
tends to lower blood sugar it's one of
the the safer drugs that you can get
anywhere and it's also on the list over
on WH o--'s list of essential medicines
for Humanity so why do I mention that
because if you if you feed it animals
they they are healthier - can live
longer and also in studies that have
looked at tens of thousands of people on
this drug those people on average tend
to be not just resistant or or doing
better for type two diabetes but other
diseases like cancer heart disease
Alzheimer's needing frailty it seems
that those people on the drug actually
have less chance than somebody that
never takes the drug so the reason I
mentioned that is that there may be
drugs already out there that are going
to be part of a future cocktail that
people can go on in their midlife you
know under doctor's supervision to make
sure it's all safe but you know I don't
think we're that far away in terms of
the science we're pretty much there and
I know I know you're not a futurist but
given your area of research I'm sure
people ask you questions so I will ask
you a little bit more about that Wendy I
mean do you think that in 30 years
we could be talking about a human
lifespan that is appreciably longer 5 10
15 years longer uh you might be
surprised if there wasn't again you know
we live in a time where where the
average lifespan is going down so that's
that's tragic and difficult but in 30
years when we're over this current
crisis and this research that I'm
talking about and and new new areas that
are emerging have blossomed and give
nice medicines yeah I think five years
is is not that challenging making it to
fifty years is you know another fifty is
much harder but there's some new
technologies that are exciting that are
complementary to this nad work there's a
way to delete old cells and and hurtful
cells in the body these are called
senescence cells there are some human
trials that look promising out of Mayo
Clinic for example and how do they do
that how do they delete the the
senescent cells i've read about the
issue with senescent cells and i know
things like fasting can help with the
autophagy but how do you do that in a
trial well scientists have looked for
molecules that either singly or
typically in combination will kill us in
essence cell but not hurt the natural or
they're healthy cells and the problem is
that those senescent cells are just
stuck in a in a zombie-like state and
you need to trigger their death process
so that's what those molecules do and
when you do that in a mouse at least
there are a lot healthier and you don't
need a lot of senescence cells to cause
havoc
Jim Kirkland from Mayo Clinic put just a
dab of senescence cells into a mouse and
it had more signs of aging so that's one
way the other area that's of interest is
actual reprogramming of the body to be
young again not just slowing down aging
but but literally turning back the clock
of the body and the reason I bring up
that one in particular
besides that we work on it is that that
to me is a game changer if that works
and it's safe in humans you could
potentially roll back the clock a decade
in the body and what what does that mean
is is is that you know I know decades
ago people talked a lot about telomeres
which are kind of those what we thought
were nonsense DNA at the end of and end
of chromosomes
what what what mechanisms are you
talking about when you talk about
actually turning back the clock yeah so
I wrote a book about this if anyone
wants to follow what I'm talking about
essentially it's the idea that I have I
have a copy at all right
right right there yeah yeah it's so this
was 20 years of my thinking all rolled
into one book and the idea
besides tips on how to live longer the
idea is a novel one which is that aging
is primarily a loss of information in
the body and that our old cells just
lose the ability to read the right genes
at the right time and we've known this
occurs but very few people have thought
that that's what's driving all these
other problems and so we've done
experiments in my lab some of which
we're about to publish which say that
you can cause aging do forwards by
disrupting that information and then we
can also reprogram cells to get that
information back again and that's the
BET's of game-changer how is it possible
to restore the age of a cell isn't that
information gone forever if you break us
a compact disc or a DVD how you possibly
going to put that back together but what
we're seeing in the lab is that if you
just turn on some very specific genes
that are normally only on when are you
very very young in the womb the cells
have the ability to reset their age not
back to zero but far enough that the
cells now are behaving like they're
young again
and literally when you measure their age
and we have a way of doing that now
there's a there's a clock we can
measuring so they are literally young
again and I mean that is to put it
lightly mind-blowing and I know like you
you want to speak about it in very
tempered ways because it leads to very
big possibilities or questions many of
which people have been asking on social
media you know let's let's put our
science fiction hat on let's say that
that works that you know in 10-15 years
there are therapies that go along the
lines that you are saying I think I'm
almost afraid to say what it could imply
because that people would think that I'm
I'm I'm dreaming but in a world where
you could I mean I guess you know keep
you know someone who Norman year old
looks like a 30 year old type of sin
and then therefore could live much much
longer
you know people there's there's all
these philosophical questions people ask
about you know from YouTube the bez
speaker says if nobody aged what will
happen to the earth will we have to
build more land Samara from Facebook is
saying I would be so worried about
medication that it increases longevity
we'd be tempering tempering with the
circle of life what I'm sure you get a
lot of that what what what how do you
view it what do you think this creates
problems or this creates solutions or we
don't know well yet the last part of my
book talks about this about the good and
the bad that may come of this now the
good I think is to me obvious we're
hoping to do our first clinical trial in
under two years from now to turn back
the age of the eye and in my suit it's
pretty easy we can turn back the age of
an old eye in a mouse and restore its
vision we can treat glaucoma pressure in
the eye
we can create even optic nerve damage so
there are parts of the body that I think
it will initially benefit and if it's if
it's your sister or your child or your
parent who's been injured or has a
disease like I think it you'd be
hard-pressed to say I'll don't give them
a medicine it's the circle of life let
them suffer you know that that's the
easy part but if you want to you know
get into the ethics if we really are
able to turn back the clock 10 20 30
years in in people yeah what does the
world look like and that's a very
important question so some of the work
that I've been doing is with economists
to see what happens as you know people
live longer the important thing about
the economy I should mention is that
when people are old and sick it's a huge
drain you know in the u.s. we're
spending seventeen percent of GDP on
healthcare and that's mostly because of
the elderly if older people are still
productive and healthy and then die
fairly rapidly that's a massive saving
in the trillions of dollars so for the
u.s. within even just the first decade
and global economy would thrive so that
economically it's not going to be the
big issue that you might think and
actually also you mentioned population
if you do the numbers I'm sure if we if
nobody ever dies that's a problem and I
wouldn't even say that's something
trying to do but am i trying to give
people more health and prevent suffering
absolutely and actually even if we
stopped anyone dying today the rate of
population growth would be less than
immigration in the u.s. so it's not
going to ruin the world anytime soon we
have bigger problems to worry about than
that and I think by having you know
saving these trillions of dollars that's
money that can be put towards solving
the you know the problems that we really
need to solve right now in housing
unemployment and climate change right
and you mentioned in the book but it you
know the the kind of crowding issue is
much more of a not only just eight life
span but there's reproduction and and
there's a good argument that is people
become wealthier and more productive and
and and more economically productive
those are the countries that are
actually having shrinking populations
and and so so ya know they're it's a
fascinating what is your well I I'm sure
people well I don't know if if if you
mind me saying this my so for those who
don't know my wife and I my wife Oh
ma'am and I met David at a conference a
couple of years ago and I had been
following his work for a long time so I
was very excited to meet him we started
chatting and we were and I know this is
kind of a flip dimension of all of this
you're you're serious researcher but
you're clearly doing something right
anyone looking at this screen right now
would assume that I'm like 10 years
older than you but I think you're 10
years older than me 81 but I haven't
shaved in a while and having had a
haircut in a while but thank you for
saying that yeah I mean we'll see I
think the proof is in the pudding and
I'm trying to live the life that that I
think is the healthiest as a role model
you know I if I if I didn't do what I'm
telling all this to do and be
hypocritical so I try to exercise I try
to eat well I tried it if I can skip
breakfast and even have a late lunch my
father does something very similar and
you know we'll see neither of us is sick
at all
my father was eighty close to 81 and as
vibrant as ever I think he's even
stronger than me last time we checked
but you know I'm not trying to prove
anything I'm not worried about
myself I'm just curious to see what
happens and I'm measuring things and
myself to try and gain insights into
what works and what doesn't and this is
an look yeah I'll give the same
disclaimer I've given several times you
know neither of us are doctors neither
of us were trying to give advice or sell
pharmaceuticals etc but I am curious I
mean you mentioned you do a few things
actually and we have that in common
I also do intermittent fasting I you
know as we speak I haven't eaten for
about 20 hours so so you know I do that
I've actually recently become
pescetarian I I like fish a lot so
that's taking a little bit harder to let
go of and so I try to do a lot of these
things than you're right regardless of
what it does to lifespan I just feel
better I feel healthier I have much more
mental clarity during the day and
actually in a fasted state once again
not medical advice don't do it while
you're growing kids but when you're an
adult you can think about it read the
research decide for yourself what other
things do you I mean or at least would
you recommend people research and make a
decision for themselves if it makes
sense or you know other people in the
field to think yeah this probably a good
idea
it might make sense well yeah the
exercise is the other thing besides
eating less and again you know we're not
talking about malnutrition starvation no
you need a healthy diet and you can make
up for it with your other meals but what
we find in animals and in humans is that
being hungry for a little part of the
day turns on these defenses but exercise
let's turn to that so right in front of
me no you can't see this anybody but I
have a gym which is attached to my
bedroom you know I'm sure that's hard
for you have a gym attached to your
bedroom I do
I sure you took more often but yeah I do
I really try to work out I've got a
treadmill of God weights and looking at
my father he's been doing this for many
more years than I have it's essential
for helping in your old age and it's not
just about maintaining your muscle mass
which is of course you lose that as you
get older it's also flexibility so if
you fall over you'll bounce and you also
you know you won't tear anything and
that's just as important so keep that
flexibility keep the muscle strength up
but also if you exercise just for
it's been shown just for 10 minutes a
day lose your breath that'll also
activate these longevity pathways these
genes that I talked about and so it
doesn't take that much you don't need to
be a marathon runner to get a lot of the
benefits we're talking about and I've
read about that as well and actually a
lot of trainers and these days advocated
with these high-intensity training it
would you just said it was interesting
you said lose your breath that's kind of
what you see is one of the key factors
there is there some evidence that when
you get winded that that stimulates some
of these pathways right that seems to be
the case that just walking will be good
for you but yeah if you can just get
hypoxia going the lack of oxygen then
you stimulate all sorts of things like
boosting those energy-producing
mitochondria and it's borne out in
studies of people who particularly
elderly people get studied you know
there's a great place down University of
Florida where they test what's good for
older people and it is very clear that
losing your breath is the best thing I
don't find it pleasant losing my breath
you know some people do but I'm not in
that camp so I push sleds when I'm at
the gym I try to run a little bit and
that that's that's the least you should
do actually and just fine these
conversations I'm sorry we're we're
already over time but I one last
question because obviously we're having
this conversation about health and aging
in a time where there's a global
pandemic and you touched on it a little
bit that you know molecules like nad
might have a benefit in encoded and
kovat is an example that has clear age
correlations where as far as I know
there's zero or a handful of cases of
children being seriously sick from kovat
and the risks just you know go up
exponentially as you get older what what
do you understand
you know how much have you directly
studied co vid what do you understand
about why do you think it has such a
strong age correlation essentially kids
don't get it or or they get it but they
don't they don't have any of the real
the bad symptoms yeah so I wrote a
review on this which i think is fairly
available to anybody so if you google my
name you should be able to read about it
there are there are lots of explanations
or potential explanations I don't think
anybody really knows there's everything
from changes to how proteins are
modified
through to exhaustion of our immune
system as we get older even having lots
of viral infections during our lifetime
can exhaust that part of a possible
explanation does include nad and you
know a lot of people you know probably
roll their eyes you know can Sinclair
talk about anything else but nad and
during the beginning of the pandemic I
resisted really trying to figure out if
an ad happened to roll but more and more
evidence came up so we've had a study in
my lab for the last few years that shows
that nad depletion occurs when or lack
of nad occurs when there's an infection
you know that's one bit of evidence but
then there was another study Charlie
Brenner professor showed that patient
samples actually have low nad if they
have bad coded infection and then there
are some are case studies coming out of
cedars-sinai hospital patients that did
remarkably well given an nad booster
cocktail so all of that led me to look
more and more into it and it turns out
but that my lab and now our Charlie's
lab was also shown that the virus is
depleting nad in the body it does that
for reasons we're not really sure but it
might be part of the pathogenesis as we
call it part of the problem that the
virus causes and so the hope and we're
testing this now and hopefully soon in
patients is that by getting that nad
depletion back up to normal that elderly
people will have the energy and the
immune system to be able to fight the
virus and there's another thing that's
interesting is that that hyper
information where these severe cases
actually succumb to over inflammation of
the cytokine storm that we know that if
you have less nad you get this hyper
activation and so that's another
possible way that nad boosting could
actually help people with a very extreme
late stage form of code 19 so that's
interesting there's this because you
know when you see the cytokine storm as
you mentioned that's for the you know
when inflammation that's your immune
system is kind of going in attacking a
bunch of stuff cytokines are our cells
and you're in your in your immune system
and that's one of the causes of severe
or illness or even death of of kovat
it's actually because of her
it's coral its asserted with when people
have low nad they're more likely to have
a cytokine storm that's that seems
counterintuitive because I was
associated nad with ATP production and
and metabolism but that you can be
overactive is my intuition off or well
the the critical determinant of this is
called the inflammasome and there's a
protein called nlrp3 and a couple of
labs have shown that the nad levels
directly control the activity of that
protein and that if you don't have
enough nad that inflammasome complex
goes berserk and then you know one thing
leads to another and you can switch it
off so it hasn't been proven in humans
of course but in cells and in mice it
has been shown that low nad
in those older animals leads to this
hyper activation Wow Wow
well I I could as you know I you know
you probably had trouble getting away
from me when I met you a couple of years
ago we could talk for hours but we're
already well over the the scheduled time
but uh thank you so much David for for
joining and having this conversation
which I clearly AM deeply intrigued by
well Sal it's great to see you again and
thanks for having me on
yeah well well thanks everyone for
joining today as always fascinating
conversation I've I wasn't joking when I
said I called David's worked for many
decades and have his book right over
there I I recommend folks to take a look
at it if you're if you've been intrigued
by this conversation
it's called lifespan but I look forward
to seeing you and I think is it day
after tomorrow or tomorrow me see I have
it on the oh there you go tomorrow
Felipe's all right there for me so I'll
be tomorrow with a with an ask me
anything and then on Thursday we're
gonna have jacqueline fuller the vice
president and president vice president
vice president of Google and president
of google.org to talk about all of the
work they do around the world including
some of which is is actually helping us
do our work at Khan Academy so thanks
everyone for joining and I will see you
tomorrow and then on Thursday
you
you